The process of bootstrapping
is probably different for
every individual or
business that's trying to do it.
But in essence, I think it breaks
down into a few core phases.
One, identification of need.
I need money, or I need this thing.
I need this value.
Once you've identified what that is,
that kind of turns into your goal.
And then it's what do I have that
can help me get that thing that I've
identified that I need?
So if it's money I maybe
need more customers.
How do I get more customers?
Well, I have this stuff
that's in my inventory or
I have the skill that I can apply or
I have this resource that I can break
down into smaller pieces and sell.
Something that you have at your
disposal already that you can then
scale its value rapidly.
And then it's the act of actually
doing that and following through and
while doing that figuring out how to
turn it into a sustainable offering so
that way it doesn't
just die out over time.
So to summarize it's three phases,
identification of problem,
location and
allocation of immediate resources and
the third thing that's important that
kind of encompasses the other two is
figuring out the longevity of
whatever it is you've done.
Summary of bootstrapping is
identifying what do you want.
What's your goal?
What is the thing that you
were trying to achieve?
Second thing is looking for
that item or skill or talent or
resource that thing that will
generate the value for you.
And the third thing is identifying how
you can turn that into a sustainable
platform to continue that
growth into the future.